وضع خطير للغاية
يتكشف في جنوب كاليفورنيا مع
هطول أمطار قياسية
وفيضانات مفاجئة وانهيارات طينية، هذا فيديو جديد
لعملية إنقاذ دراماتيكية في سان برناردينو، وقد
حوصر العديد من الأشخاص في هذه السيارة
بعد أن جرفتها مياه الفيضانات العارمة
وعلقتها على شجرة
تمكن فريق الإنقاذ على متن القارب من إنقاذهم
الآن حيث يتحدث أكثر من 11 مليون
شخص عبر كاليفورنيا تحت خطر كبير
من حدوث فيضانات خطيرة تهدد حياتهم أه
هذا هو المشهد في هوليوود هيلز
حيث تحذر خدمة الأرصاد الجوية الوطنية
من انهيارات أرضية محتملة هذا
الصباح  يمكنك رؤية أكوام من الصخور الطينية
والحطام في الشوارع، وقد
حذر خبراء الأرصاد الجوية من أن هذا سيكون أحد
أكثر أيام الطقس دراماتيكية في
الذاكرة الحديثة بالنسبة للأمطار الغزيرة في لوس أنجلوس، حيث
تسببت بالفعل في هطول
أمطار تعادل أكثر من شهر على تلك المدينة.